most of the time women want the guy that  other women want because women  essentially like competition  they the thing is I think it's it's not  even a conscious thing sometimes it is  but I think sometimes the subconscious  thing I think if if we were to bring  like three other women into this room  right now right  um they would be sizing the ladies up in  this room right they'll be like oh what  is her hair like what's she got makeup  on do you know what I mean like what's  she wearing like women like competition  like that's how they are and the thing  is they're in that competition because  of men  because they're looking generally  looking for the same guy yeah